I feel like I could eat a horse!
I want to eat burgers and fries.
Wait, maybe I should keep a healthy diet.
I can't keep eating junk food because I can see that Americans are getting fat.
Where should I start?
Did you know that Memphis is America's fattest city?
According to some researchers,...
...almost 34 percent of Memphis residents are affected by obesity problems.
Memphis is where my dad is from, so I often go and visit the place.
I didn't notice a difference until now,...
...and I can recall that there are many fast-food restaurants in Memphis.
Anyways, researchers revealed that high rates of poverty is one reason for obesity.
Let me get this straight.
Poverty is what makes them fat?
How come?
Well, people in Memphis value certain types of dishes,...
...most likely foods fried in batter, over healthier choices.
But healthier food is expensive,...
...so that is the most important reason why poor people are getting fatter and fatter.
Back to my point,...
...obesity is becoming a major problem in America as it causes heart disease,...
...and many other kinds of illnesses.
This unhealthy ratio of weight to height is becoming the leading preventable cause of death in America.
I guess it's time for Americans to adopt a good list of healthy diet habits from Asian countries,...
...especially Korea and Japan.